give this country to China picture this
you get into the skull and bone Society
you're in the Tomb you're finally there
and you go what are we going to do we we
we got Coke or something they go no no
no no we're GNA we're going to take down
the pictures of William F Buckley and
then we're going to put up posters about
how mad we are that uh he was white they
pulled the portraits down and replace
them with homemade signs portraits is a
relatively straightforward and easy ask
one member who part participated in the
redecoration told me the way a space
looks can have a large impact on a
person's psyche can you imagine a member
of the Skull and Bones being like well
actually the physical environment has a
very big impact on someone's psyche the
way a place looks give this country to
China give it to China now